open air earbuds are all the rage these
days and today we have the one more fit
SE open earbuds s30 and the one more fit
open earbuds s50 now these two come in
at separate price points and I'm shocked
at the price of the one more s30 is the
regular price is really low but they are
on sale right now so you guys can use
the links down in the description now
here we have the case and it's pretty
large as far as the size but it's
Slimmer and these are the s30 is right
here so you guys can see just like most
open a earbuds um they have this little
hook that goes behind your ear to make
sure that these stay in place if you're
being active let me pull back these
little covers for the charging pins and
as far as battery life these get up to
30 hours with the charging case and they
are designed to be very lightweight so
you don't feel them kind of weighing
down your ears now with that they have
14.2 mm drivers um so they can output a
good amount of sound and they are ipx 5
water resistant so if you're outside and
it's raining you don't have to worry
about that they are also sweat resistant
and they have four ENC microphones built
in now as far as comfort right now I
barely feel the one on my left hand side
the one that right I think I spun it a
little bit too much let's go ahead and
adjust it and the point of open ear or
open air earbuds is the fact that you
don't have anything actually going into
your ear canal now for some people if
you have them in for an hour or maybe a
little bit longer it starts to hurt and
just that pressure can build up so with
this you don't have to worry about that
at all and with that you can also hear
your environment so if you're outside
running you're working out you can hear
what's going on around you so it's
definitely safe in that aspect and they
use a dynamic transmission technology
for for the sound uh with a dynamic coil
and low frequency uh tuning for the
low's which is an area where many of
these style of earbuds um don't Excel as
well so we're going to be testing this
out in just a bit now as far as comfort
they feel great and of course with those
hooks even shaking my head like crazy I
feel my hair going around but these are
not going anywhere and then we have the
new one more s 50s for a more refined
Sport and listening experience as you
guys can see the box is nice with this
flap and this metal here definitely a
little bit more premium we have this
nice graphic and these do cost more
money but I'm still surprised at the
price points especially with the sales
going on right now let's gohe and pop
this little cover off and as you guys
can see the earbuds themselves are
actually out of the case and I can pull
this out and this case is a bit
different um it is not as long as the
s30 is it's a little bit tall taller and
thickness it's about the same and these
also come with this little carrying bag
where you can pull the string and
tighten it up just a nice little
protective uh cover for it and with that
of course we get a charging cable just
like we would do at the s30 is but we
also have these little tips on the
inside that attach now these are not
like your standard um earbud tips where
they go inside your ear canal these are
different and it's a very smart design
if we look at the actual earbuds
themselves eles you see that right here
so it actually can press against your
ear lightly and it's really cushioned
over here but there are also little
cutouts so you still get the open ear
experience where you hear all the sounds
around you so that's a benefit but
you're going to get a little bit better
sound and better bass as well now
comparing both of these the S 50s
actually look smaller and although
they're packed with more inside the
weight is actually identical so that is
impressive and one thing that I noticed
is that this has a super nice soft touch
material and everything just feels nice
and comfortable let's go ahead and pop
these on okay this is very interesting
because even though we have those little
tips on there I don't really feel them
they're so soft um that they're not
applying any pressure or anything like
that now these earbuds actually come
with fast charging 5 minutes gives you 2
hours of playback and with the total of
the case you get 30 8 hours with the S5s
and then 11 for the earbuds themselves
now these also use Bluetooth 5.3 and
they have upgraded ipx7 water and sweat
resistance and the cool thing is the s50
is come with wireless charging built
into the case these also have four
microphones but this time they are using
AI NC which is environmental noise
reduction with neural network algorithms
that can actually reduce noise in your
environment by up to 30 DB and that
helps for intelligent HD calling and now
let's go ahead and connect them and
listen to the audio quality right here
in the app they give you a little guide
and the same thing with the touch
controls now let's play our Max Tech
favorite man it's interesting that the
Sound Stage is very wide because they're
not stealed in your ear okay let's turn
this up here okay this is actually a lot
better than I expected for the price
point the volume is louder than some
that are double or triple the price the
base is actually not bad for an open ear
design and these are the s30 is that
have a very low price point all right so
now I am very excited to listen to the
S5s because those already impressed me
so now I have the one more s50 is in and
right here in the app just to give you
guys a brief look we have Smart Auto
pause and play when you take them off or
print them in you have a lot of settings
like latency customization you have a
full equalizer we can do all these
settings in here so you can definitely
use the app and tune and customize the
settings to your liking and now let's
hit play okay right away the vocals are
smoother they're standing out more let's
go ahead and turn this
up okay these definitely get louder than
the s30
is
the the base in these is better than any
open air earbud I have heard these
actually sound nice I am honestly
impressed with both of these um the s30
is for the price tag um like I said they
sounded better than um other ones that
cost way more and these are the best
open ear buds that I have tried and the
base is actually enjoyable where usually
that is what lacks now these use one
More's Innovative acoustic Engine with
the Dual circuitry design and that
increases the magnetic field Force by
40% which is why they get louder and
they also mention that even at high
volume volumes you have very little to
no Distortion and I definitely heard
that because with others that I've used
if you max out the volume then the
quality goes down dramatically but with
these they sound great and these have
Master tuning by a four-time Grammy
award winner in an audio engineer and
you can go through and you can add base
boost and other stuff but I don't think
you need it because the built-in tuning
sounds really good so if you guys are
looking for open earbuds check out the
s30 is and and the S5s buy one more they
have a really great sale going on and
you get an incredible amount of value
for the money so we're going to have
links down in the video description go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one